hello everybody my name is markiplier
and I'm here with Bob and Wade in
totally the past hey guys hi hey
so yeah yo games yeah we were playing
video games and the developer of this
game which is called a dirty bomb which
we just played and it's really really
fun they approached us and asked us if
we wanted to play this so this video is
sponsored by the developers of dirty
bomb but thankfully we're not actually
selling you anything because this game
is free and apparently fun yeah
definitely it will be a lot of fun when
we actually play it yeah there's nothing
we have played it already a future yeah
exactly
also we're an indie pop con so come say
hi to us if you're seeing this from
there how many places are we in I'm so
confused I don't know we got like three
separate time lines going here so what
did the story get so messed up yeah I'm
gonna listen to the comments too like it
sorta through oh but also because this
is a sponsored video Bob Wade and I all
agreed to donate a thousand dollars
apiece to charity I'm donating mine to
doctors across borders wait is that the
name of it that's right Doctors Without
Borders I think without Boris re Doctors
Without Borders which is a great cause
that sends doctors to other countries to
help countries in need that might be in
trouble their health care is not as good
and Bob and Wade are also going to be
donating money
so yes my portion is going to go to the
Alzheimer's Association the American
Alzheimer's Association cuz we're in
America they do they put a lot of money
towards research they also do a lot of
services for families trying to take
care of patients who have Alzheimer's or
dementia diseases which can be tough if
you have any experience it's extremely
tough so they do good work with families
and people suffering from those
conditions and my charities the Crohn's
and Colitis foundation of America I
haven't know a couple people that have
Crohn's disease which is a very nasty
bowel disease autoimmune I think I think
attacks your autoimmune system prevents
you from digesting properly getting
nutrients out of food and stuff and you
have to be on medication for life it's a
really nasty disease and this one's for
my friends and for everyone suffers from
the Crohn's and Colitis yeah so we're
gonna get on with the fun or at least
you're gonna see us get on with the fun
in a weird
wibbly-wobbly timey-wimey way very weird
I see what you did here thanks Gary
I love self-referential material as
my markup Liars might know it
self-referential until they get to you
and see the loops back here can we shine
in the face with a skillet so you
wouldn't talk like that we shut up mom
they don't even know that yes Oh mrs.
Thawne bottom sure is very direct with
her words now we have to come back and
finish the outro cuz we didn't actually
outro okay yeah so we could do a setup
outro alright so wait alright see it's
got a health bar so shoot it a lot ok
yeah shoot a table I'm shooting the guy
who's laying on his back on the ground
in the dick hole to do doctor bad thing
I'm literally I just how do I keep like
sorting round about it I just I shot at
him three times in the dick hole he's
not dead yet oh he's not dead yet I just
keep shooting him that was just
tasteless mark I can't believe
markiplier is stooped to such knows a
guy can get jump Snipes in this game do
you think it's that kind of game yeah of
course it's that kind of game
ah oh well oh that was that thing they
said in the tutorial that they didn't
let us actually use are we winning
losing I think you guys are currently
winning losing [ __ ] we're only playing
haha I killed that guy oh I got killed
ha ha ha that was me didn't know and he
stabbed my body how dare you how about
her you dick hole I was a woman though I
don't have a dick hole I'm gonna show
you in the boobs hole oh no wait what
they delivered the object oh we're not
even fighting in the right spot what are
we doing over here
hey idiots why are we fighting over here
oh I saw you just get mowed down just do
what the minigun is so overpowered Oh
was that you shoot me in the dick hole
that was me leader he was your dick hole
your face because that's where I shot
you my entire body is my dick hole whoa
give me a no wait mo me mo mo my face
mo all over me I'm so ready yeah more
ammo that's all I can do okay all right
so makeup oh wow you guys have a sniper
who's actually good yeah his name's
Snipes
yeah well certainly but unfortunately
it's not you wait yeah uh you had to
make fun of me and make fun away yeah
it's all things we go with what you know
when things are going bad you're getting
so bone around right now
Oh is around almost over is it 20
seconds left that guy's name was spanked
by come on bud
yeah we're done for today
well done what do you mean is it done as
the missiles over yay
hey balls we won I don't say in place we
weren't supposed to be doing so well you
know what place you got I was set it on
the thing so uh hey how's enforce that's
like your wife you wait I better kill
death in you mark you don't know that
says so oh well then you definitely do
know that we're on the same team now I
can get the guy all no I can't anymore
neck stretch I'm gonna get the guy with
the turret or you can get the girl with
the hair I can't I don't have the money
for I need what if I got like 13,000
credits for that round you got I did
discredits huh yeah I got like 13,000
for that round
I got 13,000 - yeah so it won't be long
until I can actually unlock that
character that's actually not bad
because most of these free-to-play games
are usually way yeah I was gonna be like
a results like 90 thousand credits to
unlock the tier two whatever the hell I
was I was a tryharding haha I'm gonna be
Wade was all oh my god who would even
drop an airstrike inside yeah do your
best Derek I don't know who Derek even
is oh yeah this guy oh my god does it
tell me what Derek is how dare he not
know who Derek it Derek is the pivotal
player in all of our last place
Derek is the guy who lurks in your
comment sections and tells you why
you're an idiot
oh that guy yes Ontario hates behind
they judge me for coming I'm feeling all
over myself but that means what look
that Derrick are you hurt okay
you all right I was that a good Derrick
oh my god wallak on to them Jesus I
walked into their spawn room whoops
you know here mark I'm reviving you know
that was I think I think you blew into
pieces I'm pretty sure those are your
body parts everywhere I think those are
your body parts man someone's currently
reviving me Bobby I blow yeah I don't
know why'd you blow up man
I don't know I'm just uh I got this hot
bod that's ready oh wait there's a
sniper above us to the left come flawed
I'm trying my best okay were you trying
your best to rhyme with hot bod yeah it
was not happen what up whenever one
whenever anyone uses the word bod it
reminds me of those commercials for bod
man body spray from like 30 2003 was
just obscene like dudes and there were
just ladies who are like I want your bod
oh really hot but I want your bah
I knew it is Derek and Derek was like oh
my god if I get botton and body spray
I'm gonna get all the chicks I thought
you're gonna go the route of I thought I
wanted by hot dive bar I what your guys
please no Derek saw my fault so great
googly mooglies run away are we doing by
the way we're trying to keep them from
doing things
I think the trying to keep them so good
that they haven't been able to do
anything there's a vehicle back towards
where we spawned we have to prevent them
from like fixing the vehicle and doing
stuff with it and stuff hmm who's your
youtube comment section lurker Wade um I
have no idea chastity song britches
maybe well the let's play wait next time
give it some more ass everyone loves the
let's play yeah let's play ass is a very
different game we don't want to play
I feel so inadequate being the heavy guy
with
this shotgun cause the other guys think
they guns are so big they're oh it's an
active you deploy the the minigun as an
active for the big guy
oh I'm going to kick so much ash Derek
are you going to wreck I'm going to play
after you finish drinking ask what will
you do there
yeah all party I just got a finished
first and then we're um to find out oh
[ __ ]
mark crack your mo oh my god I've
getting all of the finishes on those
skills but I'm not getting Hannibal oh
dammit
wait I'm right next to you behind you
wait wait wait stay stay
oh it was you I am awaited that hey
where where are you guys I'm gonna meet
up with you I want to be rude we're back
behind where you just were wrecking in
that little hallway area oh okay I got
you I'm gonna we're outside always still
oh [ __ ] disable it that's how the hell
are we oh the [ __ ] tank thing is I'm
damaging it okay
ow something hurt no it save me Wade I
got blown to oblivion Wow okay that
thing is like done okay okay you're
supposed to let it go guys we just save
it
wait I saw you die in front of you so
sad I got your back ball about thank you
where'd you get a minigun I told I was
just talking about this wait why where
did you not hear that Oh sing Wade Wade
they're pushing here we go ow
okay I don't shut
yeah oh who else rented a special f1 why
even Oh No why even I'm Nigel Oh eggs is
she's right no no no Thursday's love
that reference is getting older by the
day
a single book reference why is it
getting older by the hip stage love
everything gets older by the day Wade
okay mine alone
it's like brutally stabbed to dude in
the face who is spawn camping us nice oh
no that is the kind of violence of which
Derek is a fan I don't know why I just
did tasks chastity thong bottom which
Derek is Lana yes is chat too strong
Derek's mother um just [ __ ] out little
boy oh my god
don't Erik Lora that's exciting I never
thought Derek ah Derek would have a
backstory but he does okay everyone's
probably related she has to be at this
point he's a 46 or 47 year old man he
still lives with his mother who is now
chastity thong bottom ooh she does sweet
song bottom is at the fullness and
riches was the name bottom where song
bottoms our maiden name she changed it
went up America like Great Britain kind
of like Longbottom actually it sounds
like a
uh-uh-uh-uh-uh-uh Lord things one of
that what are they with Hobbit it sounds
like a hobbit named dong bottom bottom I
love vishaya
it's my home and I'll never forget it
why can't everyone shut up mom so
embarrassing I'm not hon just have hairy
feet oh this is a confusing family
oh so anyway so if you're at indy popcon
and you see us say hi from the past
oops I don't know let's wait back to
their attic apopka okay they're watching
this in the future but it's our past but
when they see this it'll be our present
if I'm still alive say hi to me hmm
if I'm not I fell John Connor - watch
out
so those terminators what L tell about
their coming and eat is the important
piece to the puzzle of I don't really
understand that backstory anymore huh
yeah yeah
oh yes did he can tell you she was
around with his children ages mom you
know anything about the Terminator
franchise don't act like you do I'm Your
Mother
oh my god this is not do what I say I'm
Your Mother
oh god I forgot how could it be your
mother's a complicated woman oh let's
just say that you weren't compensated
man that was almost a throwback to
mothers a complicated man oh all right
so so shoot do the intro stuff hey meow
true stuff oh yeah
don't reveal company secrets good I
guess I realize now that my experience
bar is gonna be higher now than when we
started
okay see this is just completing the
timeline cuz we're doing the beginning
of the video at the end of the video and
then looping back around when people see
it there in the future your father knew
how to loop it back alright mom
you sound like a Doctor Who fan who's
only seen seasons 20 through 26 trying
to explain how doctor who works it loops
it back around just like you [ __ ] all
right hang on all right so wait all
right
oh thanks so much for watching us play
dirty bomb if you enjoyed this game you
can check it out it's totally free it's
a free to play game available on Steam
right now we all played it we're not
heydo like it we actually were wondering
if this is gonna be a good game and
oddly enough we had a lot of fun I mean
really about awesome you're not very um
it was really really well made it played
really well and I I thoroughly enjoyed
it so if you want to try a cool free
game check the link in the description
below thanks Bob and wait for joining me
I don't know why I'm pointing everywhere
but my pleasure thanks again everybody
and as always we will see you in the
next video bye give a doorbell boy a
goat in butter the brake on left yeah
cool
damnit I was gonna do that three boobs
sorry woman half is good right